he's the New Westminster leader of the
SNP hi it's good to see you thanks for
joining us on the program
um pleased with the result yes uh
delighted to see homes have become you
backed him all along really I did I
called it I called it I think his
proposals and what should he do about
Kate Forbes I think in terms of in terms
of care you know we need to recognize
the fact that Kate received a huge
number of votes kind of got much closer
I have absolutely no doubt that Hamza
will be having conversations with Kate
to see where they can work together
going forward now some of that may
includes discussions about ministerial
posts or cabinet secretary post I'm not
privy to such information but I have no
doubt that they're having those
discussions now and I'm sure we'll find
out in the fullness of time I mean once
the celebration
um has ended
um he's got an awful lot of work to do
not least to try to reunite your party I
I've heard this put forward I feel a bit
but if you actually look at the vote
yesterday in terms of the transfers and
this is an important Point around
two-thirds of SMP members actually cast
a vote on number one or a number two for
both K and Hamza so in many
in many aspects so that shows that the
party is not divided in the way that
people think it is and I have no doubt
that moving forward Hamza will be no
longer team Hamza no longer team k no
longer team Ash it'll be team SMP msps
and that's the important thing going
forward because it's what the party
would expect of us but it's also what
the public would expect from us some
suggestions there should be a Snappy
lecture in terms of tolerate well of
course the big difference between the
Scottish Parliament and Westminster is
that over the roads there MPS don't get
to vote forget the Prime Minister as
that's in complete contrast to Hollywood
where msps opposition parties today will
get to put forward their candidate to be
first Minister we'll obviously put
forward I haven't chosen the first
leader though have they well but the
process in Scotland is completely
different because the Scottish
Parliament the first minister is elected
in the same way the cabinet secretaries
as I understand it will be elected in
the in the coming days too by the
parliament itself that's in stark
contrast to Westminster we do things
slightly differently uh in Scotland so
the people who don't want Hamza to be uh
the leader of the Scotland will have the
opportunity to to vote against him today
so that's no to a snap election I don't
think a snap election is on the horizon
though okay one there finally is a an
election that also involves
um the Westminster Parliament probably
not until the end of next year is what
Lord Hayward was saying when he was sat
where you are the other day not least
because of what's happening with
inflation and the government may feel
the need to get that under control
before they call the next election
should it still be a referendum for
Independence as has been suggested the
de facto referendum side of things I
don't think that's going to be the pitch
that will be taken forward on this
occasion no I think what is incumbent
upon us when it comes to the
independence movement is to recognize
the stalemate the fact that we are in
this 50 50 Log Jam and we have been
there for for a long long time now so we
need to break that log down by going out
on the doors and speaking with the
people of Scotland convincing them of
our case and making a real effort to
ensure that those polls are consistently
high on that'll put on undoubted
pressure on the UK government who are
going to have their seat to that at some
point but the big question in terms of
processes why are they going to happen
it's not just this is the important
point the big question when it comes to
process it shouldn't just be a question
for us it should also be a question for
Russia soon I can perhaps most
importantly for cure storm we're in the
labor party at what point are they going
to allow the people of Scotland to have
a democratic say over their own future
because up till now cure stamina are
just one in the same on that particular
issue so it's not going to happen
they've said it's not going to happen
that's a completely undemocratic
position to take another labor probably
want to run on that Manifesto commitment
in Scotland as it appears that they do
then then bring it on because I think
it's interesting the view is that now
Nicholas sturgeon has moved aside
um the labor party May well be taking
more seats up in school well I think
that's a wishful thinking in in that
respect and there's a key reason for
that because when it comes to the big
issues of the day single Market access
Customs Union access freedom of movement
our whole entire outlook on migration
which is integral to our economy when we
look at Scotland's constitutional future
with the labor party are and where the
people of Scotland are are completely
different and when we continue to focus
on that and run up to a general election
I think the labor party are going to be
sorry for the stance that they've taken
is your new leader going to be any
better at running the Health Service in
Scotland than he was when he was in
charge I assume you're referring to the
Health Service which undoubtedly has
challenges I don't think anyone's shy
there's challenges there's absolutely no
doubt about that but we have the best
performing Health Service and these
entire aisles and that's an important
point and there's also not been a single
day of strike action from nurses in
Scotland and start contrast so yeah to
elsewhere in the UK I'd never I don't
see that kid there's undoubtedly
challenges within the Health Service but
I don't think we should discuss the
Health Service without talking about the
fact that Scotland's Health Services in
a far better place than that underneath
the conservatives in England so that's
an important point to make now there's
obviously going to be challenges waiting
on a trolley for 12 hours in a Scottish
hospital it's not doesn't doubtedly
challenges and doesn't challenges to
come but one of the biggest challenges
facing our health services the ability
to recruit something which is completely
out with our control because the UK
government decided to end freedom of
movement so the backlogs that we have
which is one of the key drivers behind
the weights in enes is because we can't
get the people into the Health Service
who would otherwise have been there
brexit ended that and again the labor
party in the conservative party are both
guilty on that front it's good to see
you as always thanks very much thank you
for joining us really appreciate it
thank you